how do you create a strong magnetic
field yeah so with a giant magnet giant
magnet yeah so it's it's basically true
engineering there's essentially there's
essentially two ways to create a magnet
so one of them is that we're familiar
with like fridge magnets and so forth
these are so-called permanent magnets
and what it means is that Within These
the atoms arranged in a particular way
that it produces the electrons basically
arranged in a particular way that it
produces a permanent magnetic field that
is set by the material so those 10 those
have a fundamental limitation how strong
they can be and they also tend to have
this like circular shape like this so we
don't use we don't typically use those
so what we use are so-called
electromagnets and what is this it's
like um so the other way to make a
magnetic field also go back to your you
know your your Elementary School physics
uh or science class is that you take a a
nail and you wrap a copper wire around
it and connect it to a battery then it
can pick up iron filings this is an
electromagnet
at its simplest what it is it's an
electric current which is going in a
pattern around and around and around and
what this does is it produces a magnetic
field which goes through it by the laws
of electromagnetism
so that's what an electro that's so
that's how we make the magnetic field in
these in in these configurations and the
key there is that you it's not limited
by the magnetic property of the material
the magnetic field uh amplitude is set
by the amount of the the geometry of
this thing and the amount of electric
current that you're putting through and
the more electric current that you put
through the more magnetic field that you
get the closest one that people maybe
see is one of my one of my favorite
skits actually was Super Dave Osborne on
any part it's probably probably past
years again a show called bizarre Super
Dave Osborne which is a great comedian
called he was a stunt man and one of his
tricks was that he was he gets into a
car and then one of those things in the
junkyard comes down you know and picks
up the car and then puts it into the
into the crusher this is his stunt which
is a pretty hilarious anyway
um but that thing that picks them up
like how does that work that's actually
not a permanent magnet it's a it's an
electromatic and so you can turn by
turning off and on the power supply it
turns off and on the magnetic field so
this means you can pick it up and then
when you switch it off the magnetic
field goes away and the car drops okay
so that's that's what it looks like
speaking of giant magnets MIT and
Commonwealth Fusion systems CFS built a
very large high temperature
superconducting electromagnet that was
ramped up to a field strength of 20
Tesla the most powerful magnetic field
of its kind ever created down Earth
um because I enjoy this kind of thing
can you please tell me about this magnet
yeah sure oh it was it's fun yeah
there's a lot to Parts there so maybe uh
we so we already explained an
electromagnet which
in general is what you do is you take
electric current and you force it to to
follow a pattern of some kind typically
like a circular pattern around and
around and around around it goes the
more time the more current and the more
times it goes around the stronger the
magnetic field that you make okay
and as I pointed out it's like really
important in magnetic confinement
because it is the the force that's
produced by that magnet in fact
technically it goes like the magnetic
field squared because it's it's a
pressure which is actually being exerted
on the plasma to keep it contained
uh just just so we know for a magnetic
confinement what is usually the geometry
of the magnet what are we the geometry
yeah so the geometry is typically that
typically is what you do is you want to
produce a magnetic field that Loops back
on itself and the reason for this was
goes down to the nature of the force
that I described
which is that there's no there's no
containment or Force along the direction
of the magnetic field so here's a
magnetic field in fact what what it's
more technically or more graphically
what it's doing is that when the when
the plasma is here's plasma particles
here there's a magnetic field what it
does is it forces all those because of
this this Lorenz force it makes all of
those charged particles execute circular
orbits around the magnetic field and
they go around like this but they stream
freely along the magnetic field line so
this is why the nature of the
containment is that if you can get that
Circle smaller and smaller it stays
further away from Earth temperature
materials that's why the confinement
gets better but the problem is is that
because it free streams along so we just
have a long straight magnetic field okay
it'll just keep leaking out the ends
like really fast so you get rid of the
ends so you basically Loop it back
around so what these look like are
typically donut shaped or more
technically toroidal shape but donut
shaped um things where this collection
of magnetic fields Loops back on itself
and it also for reasons which are more
complicated to explain basically it also
twists it also twists slowly around in
this direction as well too so that's
what it looks like that's what the
plasma looks like because that's what
the fuel looks like so then this means
is that the um the electromagnets are
configured in such a way that it
produces the desired magnetic fields
around this so they precise does this
have to be you were probably listening
to our conversation with some of my
colleagues yesterday so it's actually
it's it depends on the configuration uh
about how you're doing it the
configuration of the plasma the
configuration of the electromagnets and
about how you're achieving this this
requirement
um it it's it's fairly precise but it
doesn't have to be in particularly in
something like a Tokamak what we do is
we produce planar coils that just mean
they're flat and we situate them so if
you think of a circle like this what
does it produce if you put current
through it it produces a magnetic field
which goes through the circle like this
so if you align many of them like this
this this this this there's things
online you can go see the picture to to
you keep arranging these around in a
circle itself this forces the magnetic
field lines to basically just keep
executing around like this so you tend
to align that one tends to re well it
requires good confine or good alignment
it's not like in insane alignment
because you're you're actually
exploiting the symmetry of the situation
to to help it there's another kind of
configuration of magnetic of this kind
of magnetic confinement called a
stellarator which is we have these names
from for historic reasons which is
different than a Taco Mac it's different
than a token that actually works on the
same physical principle that namely in
the end it produces a plasma which Loops
in magnetic fields which loop back on
themselves as well but in that in that
case the totality basically the totality
of the confining magnetic field is
produced by external three-dimensional
magnets so they're Twisted
um and it turns out the Precision of
those is is more stringent